to Leslie I watched the movie I was so
moved by it I cried like a baby at the
end of this thing and so did my wife and
who do I see in this movie
you and um yeah this [__] is
some emotional actor and so moving in
this movie and like I'm so in love with
you in this movie and the woman who is
your co-star Andrea risborough
we've got the Academy Award nomination
this Andrea reisborough is such a good
actress that I would imagine that's
intimidating too I talked to a lot of
actors you do too but I talk to him
about acting I spent the last five years
once I started acting any actor I have
on I get a lesson right right so I I
integrated a lot of what they said I
knew I could listen I could be present
on screen I knew I wasn't great I mean
when I did Marin I knew just from other
Comics peers of mine who did shows I'm
gonna suck for at least a year but I'll
figure out at least how to you know you
know not be conscious of what I'm doing
with my hands so
with Andrea I get there I wasn't that
intimidated man because it was P coveted
and like somehow they had convinced me
that doing the movie would be safer than
going to the supermarket like there's
going to be protocols in place right you
know what I mean like everyone's gonna
be masked all the time I just knew that
I had to show up it was in town and uh
and do this thing and right away when
you start working with her you're like
holy [__] and then you know she's
British and she's doing this shattered
Texan uh it was astounding but I think
what helped me is that I knew right from
the beginning when I was there where
they're like well this is her movie this
is her this is a big thing for her so
the codependency that comes out in the
character I was actually feeling off
camera I'm like don't [__] this up for
Andrea all right just take care of it do
whatever you got to do to be there for
her and that was sort of the guy so it
informed that you championing the film
and and me hearing about that you know I
was I was flattered and I and I
appreciate it and I really don't think
anyone would have seen this movie yeah
it was one of those movies these it's
one of those ones you do when you're
like you know what's the worst that can
happen I suck and no one will even
[__] know it exists and all I can say
is in in retrospect thank God I did okay
but uh then there was so much
controversy with this uh Academy Award
nomination I went what are you talking
about they spend millions of dollars on
these Academy Award nominations it's all
yeah yeah and when an underdog kind of
sneaks around the side the people that
spent millions of dollars Panic yeah so
they start [__] and it's like look if
there's a problem with how social like
if you if you have an issue the academy
with how uh things are supposed to
transpire on social media platforms you
know update your rules behind closed
doors and change it for next year you
[__]
yeah
foreign